I want to look at one more clip of Nikki
Haley's recent CNN Town Hall I already
played for you yesterday on the Monday
show a clip of Nikki Haley who's running
for president in on for the Republican
nomination for president Dead on Arrival
has no shot maybe running for vice
president more than she's running for
president I already played a clip for
you of Nikki Haley sort of going
anti-trans I have another clip I want to
look at in more detail because it's so
dishonest and Incorrect and dangerous
and harmful as The Daily Beast reports
Nikki Haley blamed teen suicides on
trans kids in locker rooms trans kids in
locker rooms and this all came during
the segment about how do you define woke
I'm going to play this clip for you and
see if you can find anything that's true
here
take a listen you want to start with
biological boys playing in girls sports
that's one thing the fact that we have
gender pronoun classes in the military
now I mean all of these things that are
pushing what a small minority want on
the majority of Americans it's too much
it's too much I mean the idea that we
have biological boys playing in girls
Sports it is the women's issue of our
time what my daughter ran track in high
school I don't even know how I would
have that conversation with her how are
we supposed to get our girls used to the
fact that biological boys are in their
locker rooms what and then we wonder why
a third of our teenage girls seriously
contemplated suicide last year we should
be growing strong girls confident guys
we shouldn't be surprised about the
level of suicidal ideation and attempts
among teen girls when we see biological
boys in the locker rooms now it's hard
to find a more dishonest Incorrect and
harmful thing to be said now before we
even delve into the suicidal ideation
component of this someone wrote to me
the other day with a really good point
and this isn't this isn't about
stereotyping trans people this is just
sort of like a reality
there are very few trans people first
and foremost
and then you say okay when we go further
how many trans youth are there
playing sports obviously there are but
it is a very small percentage of trans
youth which is a very small percentage
of trans people which is a very small
percentage of the population it doesn't
mean this doesn't exist it doesn't mean
we don't need to deal with it with
empathy and empiricism and all of the
things I advocate for but the idea that
this is the issue of our time is just
laughable now let's go on to the the
data there is no evidence that trans
girls in locker rooms or in sports in
general is causing suicidal ideation in
teenage girls there is no evidence of
that in fact studies show that LGBT
students have higher rates of reported
suicide attempts themselves compared to
heterosexual and cisgendered students
okay so it's it's the opposite of what
Nikki Haley is saying the real causes of
teen Sue aside and suicidal ideation
seem to be a combination of
gun violence
um concerns about the world lack of
connection in many ways you know
violence hate bullying and yes
unrestricted what Cal Newport calls
unrestricted access to social media
seems to be really really damaging to
teens in general and to teen girls in
particular and so this is a real issue
suicide amongst teens is a real issue
Nikki Haley is using a transphobic Trope
to appeal to a conservative base to
undermine the Dignity of trans people
ignoring the scientific consensus
ignoring reality ignoring a lot of the
Empirical research we have on this issue
so she should be ashamed of herself
she's overtly spreading falsehoods out
of desperation to get attention and it's
all because her campaign is failing and
failing very quickly I think it's
important to understand here that if
Nikki Haley's campaign was doing really
well my guess is she wouldn't all of a
sudden be focusing on woken on trans if
we look at the latest data Nikki Haley's
polling 4.4 zero path even to catching
up to DeSantis never mind to actually
um uh catching up to Donald Trump so
that's what the this is all about it is
a desperate and very very troubling
search for relevance and meanwhile we
continue receiving more and more data
that anti-woke may be a really silly
tactic for these Republican elected
officials did you know that half of
Americans are deficient in vitamins A
and C as well as magnesium if you keep
your diet nutritionally balanced all the
time you can get everything you need but
half of Americans don't and it can
really impact how you feel our sponsor
athletic greens makes it super easy I
mix one scoop of ag1 from athletic
greens into water it tastes great I get
all of the high quality vitamins and
minerals I need from Whole Food sourced
ingredients I don't have to Fumble
around with bottles capsules individual
vitamins and things like that I just
don't have the time you should see
what's going on at my house ag1
simplifies everything I'm covering my
nutritional bases for the entire entire
day
super easy easy to stick to as well and
dramatically more cost effective than
getting all of these different vitamin
supplements go to athleticgreens.com
Pacman for a free year supply of vitamin
D I've talked about vitamin D many times
plus five free ag1 travel packs the link
is down below